Із цього лісу до кордону України з Росією - менш ніж 15 кілометрів.
Тут постійна небезпека артилерійських обстрілів.
А тепер ситуацію додатково ускладнює зима.
Пересуватися взимку стає важче, бо всі рухи стають одразу помітними й може будь-якої миті "прилетіти" від ворога.
Зима дійсно вносить певні корективи в нашу діяльність.
У першу чергу, це маскування і рух по заболоченій місцевості, по полях.
Звичайно, більше пересуватися ми мусимо - як ми, так і вони - по дорогах.
Або, якщо вже там будуть засніжені, замерзлі поля, то тільки тоді.
Тому що наступати чи оборонятися, коли сльота, бруд - це набагато важче.
Юрій на війні - із 2014 року.
А під час повномасштабного вторгнення він пройшов Ізюм і Слов‘янськ, тому не боїться ні обстрілів, ні морозів.
Я пройшов 2014-2015. Під Донецьком було мінус 23-25 градусів.
Тут, люди кажуть, буває і до мінус 32. Нічого, переживем, все нормально.
На думку військового, зима може сповільнити динаміку бойових дій.
Мені здається, що з приходом зими, а головне, що мабуть те, що і вони вже більше навчилися, і ми багато навчилися -
набагато краще розуміти, організація, взаємодія бойових дій.
То фронт, скоріш за все, з моєї точки зору, більш стабілізується і стане статичним.
Температура у цій місцевості вже опустилася до нуля.
Солдати гріються в хижі посеред лісу. Топлять пічку і готуються зимувати на фронті.
Ми зараз майже її не топимо, там два поліна і все.
А так більше дров - більше жару. У будь-якому випадку перезимуємо. Хай навіть буде і мінус 40.
Каже, будуть пристосовуватися і знаходити рішення, як зігрітися.
Найголовніше, щоб техніка працювала. Прогрівати вчасно, щоб були рідини спеціальні.
А так специфіка - яка різниця? Що зимою, що літом стріляти.
Обслуговування техніки - от у чому вся специфіка війни взимку.
Заходять погрітися і до цього будинку в сусідньому селі.
Військові кажуть, що він належить колаборантам.
У цьому будинку особисто жили "любителі русского міра".
Ті, які зустрічали окупантів з хлібом-сіллю,
ті, які здавали місцевих, здавали сімей, у яких, наприклад,
військовослужбовці їхні родичі, які у Збройних силах України.
За зраду - отримували гроші від окупантів.
Коли наші війська сюди зайшли - 11-го числа піхота зайшла, - то вони корову під ніж і 13-го числа їх уже не було.
Забрали, що тільки можна. Дехто каже, що вони поїхали на Харків.
Дехто каже, що на Росію. Я не знаю.
В усякому разі, вони сюди зараз повертатися бояться.
Бояться нашого правосуддя, бо все-таки це зрадники, зрадники власної батьківщини.
Солдати зміцнюють старі радянські танки уламками трофейної російської техніки.
Маскуватися листям більше не вийде.
Ще звичайно не така зима, але вночі в нас доходило до мінус 7-10 градусів і, знаєте, не така вже й проблема ніби.
Воно звикається, поступово-поступово звикається.
Звісно, коли ти по коліна постійно в болоті, ноги мокрі - це не так приємно.
Треба знову ж таки частіше ходити грітися.
Проте воно звикається. І є напевно якась мотивація для того.
Ти розумієш, чому ти це робиш. І, відповідно, воно якось додатково зігріває тобі душу.
І це заспокоює і дає сили на наступні бої.
Сергій вважає, що попри значно складніші умови ведення бою взимку
це навряд чи зменшить запал військових ЗСУ відвоювати українські території.
Звичайно, що зараз воювати буде значно важче хлопцям.
Всім холодніше стає. І перерви, напевно потрібно десь бігти зігріватися, не завжди є така можливість.
Проте все одно я думаю, що інтенсивність не спаде.
Вона буде така сама, а можливо і навпаки наростати.
Тому що підозрюю, що нам потрібно зараз чим швидше відбивати свої території, тому немає дуже часу на паузи.
Звичайно, що важче стає, проте потрібно йти вперед.
Хто тішиться снігу, то це діти в сусідньому селі.
Узимку ми любимо ліпити сніговика, кататися на гірках, кидатися сніжками, кататися на санчатах…
Школа зачинена вже кілька місяців, навчання - дистанційне. Та й з електрикою - проблеми.
Як ми сюди заселялися, то тут до місяця не було електрики.
От вона з’явилася. І тоді, як ідуть масові ракетні удари по Україні, по інфраструктурі, то і в нас зникає електрика.
Ось два дні напередодні цього не було, тільки сьогодні з’явилося світло.
У селі ще досі не відновити газопостачання, але солдати мають свої балони з газом і похідні плитки.
Найближчими днями температура опуститься ще нижче.
Та військові налаштовані рішуче - і щодо морозів, і щодо війни.
На фронті ми їх тут завжди готові зустріти.
Тут у нас військ досить, люди навчені. Головне, що ми праві, всі мотивовані, всі воюють.
Нікого не треба так, як у них, брати з в’язниць чи ще якимось чином,
емігрантів якихось, таджиків чи узбеків залучати.
У нас всі самі йдуть, самі розуміють, що це їхня домівка і їхня держава, і всі вмотивовані.